Man 1: "We hold these
truths to be self-evident,
"that all men are created equal,
"that they are endowed by their Creator
"with certain unalienable
Rights, that among these are
"Life, Liberty, and the
pursuit of Happiness."
It's this amazing second sentence
of the Declaration of
Independence that Jefferson
and Adams and Franklin
wrote as part of a committee
and we were looking at that sentence.
Let's go on to look at that
phrase, "they are endowed
"by their Creator."
It's interesting, they don't
really mention Jesus Christ
and not even God.
They talk about the laws of
nature and of nature's god
and a creator.
These are deists, people
who believe in the notion
that there's some grand
creator of the universe,
but they don't get into the
specifics of any particular
religious dogma.
The other thing is they're
balancing where do our rights
come from?
In an earlier draft, and
we'll talk about how they edit
the earlier drafts in a later
video, but in an earlier draft
it just says they're endowed
with certain unalienable
rights and you see
that John Adams, probably,
is the one who wants
to insert the phrase "their
Creator" and that was
because they started the sentence
with "We hold these truths to be sacred,"
but they changed that to "self-evident."
They're trying to say to
what extent is it rationality
that gives us these rights, to what extent
are these rights endowed by God
and I think what they
finally come down to is
that we all had a creator
and that creator made us all.
So, to a certain sync,
we're created equal.
Our creator must love us
all, we are all created
by the same creator, therefore
there's a certain equality
that we have and in
creating us, he gave us
certain unalienable rights.
Man 2: Unalienable just
means can't be taken away.
It can't be separated.
Man 1: It can't be separated.
You can't take these rights away.
The king can't take these rights away.
In other words, it's not
as if we could give up
these rights and in
particular, they are talking
about this theory of
government that John Locke had,
who was one of the
philosophers that they read,
an English philosopher of that period,
who said that when you created government
or there is a government, you give up some
of your rights.
For example, if we all
agree that we're part
of a government, we may give up our right
to take somebody else's
property or whatever it may be.
These are rights you can give up,
but there are certain
rights that are unalienable,
that you just can't give up or
the king can't take it away.
Once again, you've got to
look at Thomas Jefferson,
who actually owned slaves at this point
and he's saying among
those unalienable rights
are life, liberty, and
the pursuit of happiness.
There's this inherent conflict
still, between rights,
such as liberty, that you
can't take away from a person
and yet, Jefferson's writing this phrase
when he owns slaves.
The phrase "Life, Liberty,
and the pursuit of Happiness"
is also something that
derives from John Locke
and these philosophers
of the Enlightenment
that were writing in England.
At one point, John Locke uses
the phrase "Life, Liberty,
"and the pursuit of property,"
because Locke believed
that owning property was
an important right you had
and the government couldn't just take
your property away.
However, you can see that they change it
to a more elevated phrase
(laughter) that we each get
to pursue our own notion
of what we want to do
in our lives, our happiness.
I don't think they just
mean happiness like joy
and frivolity.
I think they mean pursuit
of meaning in life,
what gives our life meaning
and these are the unalienable rights.
Then they go on and this gets
to what's called the contract
notion of government,
is that why do we have governments?
Whether it's John Locke
or the other philosophers
we've talked about, they say the reason
we have government is that
we all had these rights,
but we decided to get together.
We instituted governments.
Governments are instituted and the reason
those governments have
their power is because
of the consent of the governed.
It's like if you and I
and 20 people got together
and formed a group and we
said, "We're going to form
"a group, we'll give
up some of our rights,
"because the group itself
will have certain powers,
"but we're consenting to do that."
It's not because of the
divine right of kings.
It's the consent of the governed.
The consent of the people
says we will institute
a government amongst ourselves
and that's not to take away our rights,
that's to secure our rights.
Man 2: Right.
I might ...
The 20 of us might give up
our right to enforce things,
police each other, to the government,
so that we could have our life, liberty,
and pursuit of happiness.
We're more likely to have it secured.
Man 1: Once you get to that
theory, you have to say,
"What are the type of
rights we would give up?"
Such as, maybe, the right
to decide the traffic laws
or the policing of the thing,
or how property contracts
are made, but there are
certain things that,
no matter what you did,
if you were instituting
a government among men,
you would not give up
the right to life, you
would not give up the right
to liberty, and you would not
say, "I'm going to give up
"my right to pursue my own life ends,
"my own happiness."
You would say, "We want
to secure those rights.
"We're not going to give
those up to government."